have you ever heard of an economy
being taxed into prosperity
i haven't the united states has risen
from the depths
in 2016
tennessee had a two billion dollar
surplus
how do they do that
they have no income tax they have low
sales tax how do they do that
[Music]
economic policy the laffer curve is
about the most recognizable economics
graph of modern history i mean even the
people who hate it call it that
why do they hate it because it thwarts
them from taking control of your lives
the keynesians say the government drives
the economy arthur says no private
sector drives economy and inside that
framework
incentives matter
every economist understands the lab for
her they just didn't use it if you tax
people who work
and you pay people who don't work
you're going to get a lot of people not
working what you just did
was explain human nature
right and if you can understand human
nature you can understand economics
that's it arts impact on economics
enormous i mean reagan cut the highest
tax rate
from 70 percent down to 28
we made ourselves a production haven for
the world
time to reawaken this industrial giant
to get government back within its means
and to lighten our punitive tax burden
the core principle of arthur lapra's
economics is that the american economy
will always respond stupendously to
freedom whether we call it economics or
not we're making economic decisions
markets are people that's what gets lost
sighted
remove the impediments in the economy
and you will see the economy improving
itself the closure where the houses you
build the roads you drive without
economics none of this would exist
arthur revolutionized economics there's
no place in america that couldn't
benefit from laffer policy this is not
the end of america these are the seeds
to get the regrowth of america and it's
all supply side economics
it's the way the world works
greater extent
you